♪ ♪
>> YOU SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH CHINA.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
THAT SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE YEARS
AGO.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> OPERATING AGAINST THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
>> WE WANT A CONSTRUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OF CHINA.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT, WE NEED TO
REPAIR, MAKE SOME PROGRESS ON
SOME ISSUES RELATED TO TRADE.
>> WE ADVISE THE U.S. TO REMAIN
RATIONAL AND STOP SUCH WARS TO
HARM ITSELF AND OTHERS.
THIS IS THE ONLY VIABLE WAY OUT.
>> Bret: THE THREAT OF
$200 BILLION OF ADDITIONAL
TARIFFS AGAINST CHINA SENT THE
MARKETS REELING NOT ONLY HERE
BUT AROUND THE WORLD, ESPECIALLY
ASIA.
THE DOW DROPPING 400-POINT.
DOWN AT 270 AT THE END.
IT MADE THINGS ROCKY AND THERE
WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
CAPITOL HILL WEIGHING IN ON ALL
SIDES.
BACK WITH THE PANEL.
JONAH, WHAT ABOUT THE STRATEGY,
AND CAN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FORCED CHINA TO
BUCKLE?
>> AND PRETTY SKEPTICAL.
CHINA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF --
CHINA HAS A MUCH BIGGER
NATIONALISM PROBLEM THAN ALMOST
ANYTHING ELSE IN THE IDEA OF
INVESTING THEIR NATIONAL PRIDE
IN BEING SEEN AS LOSING FACE TO
THE WEST OR TO AMERICANS IS A
REAL PROBLEM POLITICALLY.
BUT ALSO, IT'S WORTH POINTING
OUT THAT THE DOW IS DOWN,
NEGATIVE FOR THE YEAR.
THE DOW USED TO BE THE
TALKING POINT ABOUT THE
INDICATOR OF HOW WELL THINGS ARE
GOING.
THEY NOW POINTED BETTER ONES
LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT AND WHATNOT.
TRADE WARS ARE NOT EASY TO WIN
AND THEY ARE VERY HARD TO END.
RIGHT NOW, STILL PRICES IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE UP 40%.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE PEOPLE
EMPLOYED BY FIRMS THAT USE STEEL
AND MAKE THEM.
THIS COULD GO SOUTH VERY QUICKLY
AND IT MAKES ME VERY NERVOUS.
>> Bret: TRADE REPRESENTATIVE
ROBERT LIGHTHIZER RUNNING POINT
ON THIS.
>> WHAT WE NEED FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS UNENFORCEABLE,
ACCOUNTABLE SYSTEMATIC CHANGE
STRUCTURAL IN NATURE SO WE CAN
HAVE FREE, FAIR, AND BALANCED
TRADE NOT JUST WITH CHINA BUT
WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
DAY, BUT THAT IS NOT THIS DAY.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN A BIG FAN OF
PETER NAVARRO.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS, IS
KIND OF GOING ALONG WITH IT.
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT HAS GOT
TO WAKE UP AND REALIZE THAT'S
NOT THE WAY TO GO.
>> Bret: A LOT PEOPLE SAY IT'S
THEY DON'T KNOW, AS JONAH SAID,
HOW IT'S GOING.
THERE'S OTHERS WHO SAY THIS
NEEDS TO BE SHAKEN UP IN THE
WORLD ORDER OF THINGS.
>> I AM ONE OF THEM.
I THINK ORRIN HATCH NEEDS TO
WAKE UP.
HE AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
CONSENSUS THAT'S BEEN BUILDING
AROUND CHINA EVER SINCE THE LATE
'90s THAT WE NEED TO ENGAGE
AND BE OPEN ALL THE REST AND IT
WILL IMPROVE THEIR BEHAVIOR,
IT'S PROVED TO BE COMPLETELY
WRONG.
EVER SINCE WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING
ECONOMICALLY WITH CHINA, THEIR
BEHAVIOR HAS GOTTEN MORE AND
MORE AUTHORITATIVE.
THEY HAVE SET OUT A PLAN FOR
WORLD DOMINATION, ECONOMICALLY
AND MILITARILY.
THEY HAVE A PLAN TO BEAT US.
WE NEED A PLAN TO BEAT THEM.
I THINK IT'S GREAT WHERE
STANDING UP TO THEM BUT FRANKLY
I DON'T THINK THESE MEASURES GO
FAR ENOUGH.
I WOULD SAY WE NEED A COMPLETE
ECONOMIC BOYCOTT OF CHINA.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY TO FACE DOWN
THIS THREAT.
IF THE WORLD IS RUN ACCORDING TO
THE VALUES OF THE AUTHORITARIAN
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP LED BY
XI JINPING, IT'S NOT A WORLD WE
WANT >> Bret: WHAT HAPPENS TO
ALL THE COMPANIES THEY DO
BUSINESS WITH CHINA?
THE WORKERS WOULD FILL IN ON THE
THIS ARGUMENT I MADE THIS
ARGUMENT.
THERE'S A WORLD OF OPPORTUNITY
BEYOND CHINA.
AFRICA, SOUTH AMERICA, INDIA,
THE GREATEST DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD BE
PUTTING OUR PARTY.
TO SUCK UP TO CHINA HAS BEEN A
COMPLETE DISASTER.
>> Bret: A.B., HOW DOES IT
PLAY POLITICALLY?
STRANGE BEDFELLOWS.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS APPLAUDING
THE MOVES FROM INCLUDING
SENATOR SCHUMER.
>> YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS LIKE THE
ONE IN OHIO OWNING THE TARIFFS
SAYING HE HAS BEEN IN THE
BERNIE SANDERS WING ON THE FAR
LEFT.
IN UNISON WITH TRUMP ON THIS FOR
A LONG TIME.
YOU HAVE OTHER REPUBLICANS IN
STATES WITH FARMERS.
I READ YESTERDAY THAT THE HIT TO
SOYBEAN FARMERS IN IOWA ALONE
WILL EXCEED $600 MILLION.
ALL THE PLANNING HAS TO HAPPEN
NOW.
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN DETERMINE
OR THE MARKET CAN DETERMINE OR
THEIR POOR REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN RUNNING FOR
REELECTION CAN DETERMINE WHAT
TRUMP IS REALLY GOING TO FINALLY
DO, ALL OF THE PLANNING THAT'S
TAKING PLACE NOW, DISRUPTION IS
UNDERWAY DOMESTICALLY AND IN A
NATIONALLY THROUGH PORTS, PEOPLE
PLANNING THEIR INVENTORY, IT'S
ALL RIPPLING OUT.
THE POOR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO GET AN
ANSWER FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
WHETHER IT'S A TACTIC OR
DEFINITELY A TRADE WAR THAT'S
GOING TO BE EASY TO WIN ARE
GOING TO BE SITTING AROUND
WAITING TO SEE THE MARKET
RESPONSE AND THE VOTER RESPONSE.
IT'S REALLY SCARING THEM.
THEY WON'T BRING IT UP WITH HIM.
BUT AS YOU KNOW IT'S ALL THE
TALK.
>> Bret: THAT'S WHAT HE
STARTED WITH IN THE MEETING.
QUICKLY, JONAH, TEND EVENTUALLY
YOU HAVE CHINA WORKING ON THE
NORTH KOREA ISSUE WHETHER THEY
ARE HELPING ARE NOT AND IT
FACTORS IN AS WELL.
>> IT DOES AND IT'S ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE DON'T KNOW.
IT'S IN CHINA AND NORTH KOREA'S
INTERESTS TO RUN OUT THE CLOCK
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE ON THESE
NEGOTIATIONS.
I THINK IS WHAT CHINA WANTS TO
DO.
I THINK NORTH KOREA IS STILL
ESSENTIALLY AN UNRULY VASSAL
STATE OF CHINA AND HOW YOU
NEGOTIATE THIS TRADE WAR STUFF
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME FIGURING
OUT HOW YOU KEEP NORTH KOREA ON
THE PATH THROUGH THIS ELEGY TO
DO LOCALIZATION SEEMS TO ME IT'S